FELIX:
For four months,
I have grown this awkward beard.
And for four months,
I have faced my demons.
Every day, should I shave?
Or should I keep it?
You bros have
either supported it,
or have been against it.
And today,
we're waving the options
whether the beard
will stay or not.
(♪♪♪)
FELIX:
Let's start why
I should keep the beard.
Cyprien.
He's like...
well je suis avec un beard.
So you better keep it as well.
He makes a fair point.
Nice fan art.
"With beard or no beard you
are our hero" oh that's sweet.
Ok, with me beard,
this is my shaving,
wiping off the face.
And I look like I'm a baby.
Thanks.
(laughing)
FELIX:
That picture's
literally from 2011.
"Look at him walking into
the room with that beard,
so majestic".
Pewds with beard,
a fucking viking beast.
Pewds without beard,
disgusting man child.
"Felix's Ancestor
found beards cool too.
Is this what you're
gonna look like?"
Yes it is.
Absolutely.
That is the best photoshop
I have ever seen.
Wow.
"You look hot with
your beard" eyy.
Damn right I do.
What the fuck is this?
Oh my god, this is amazing.
(laughing)
FELIX:
Oh that is the best fan art
I've seen in a long time,
dude, what the hell.
Salad Snake.
What make a PewDiePie?
Awesome brain of gaming nerd.
The beard
that makes the girls scream
and men jealous.
Roses are red, violets are blue.
Pewd's beard looks like a bush.
Yummy.
Hell yeah!
Does my beard have a face in it?
Oh now you're
just getting weird.
What the fu-, bruh?
Bruh.
(laughing)
Oh that's awesome.
Holy shit.
Is that me?
No way that's me,
my nose is not that handsome.
What the fuck,
that is beautiful.
Alright, now let's look at
you bros that wants me to shave.
I want this face back.
God dammit,
I do look hot as shit,
you're right.
Just do it, don't let
the beard be beard.
You make a great point.
Pewds, if you don't shave
you'll end up like this guy.
I don't see a problem.
Holy shit, look at this.
Look at this fan,
tweeting so many times.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, dude.
Retweet.
Holy sh- it never ends.
It never- oh my...
Oh my god it keeps going.
Oh there's more of them.
Jesus Christ dude!
You know what,
this is all too much.
I'm doing a vote.
And the vote
will decide once and for all,
this vote is final.
(drumroll)
50-50?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh wait, it's been updated.
The results are in.
52% Pewds beard.
48% Pewds shave.
You know what that means?
I'm keeping the beard.
But guess what, I'm PewDiePie.
If I wanna shave, I'll shave.
Just watch me.
(♪♪♪)
(shaver buzzing)
(thunder)
What the fuck?
MAYA:
I have been watching you child,
for 26 long years.
(♪♪♪)
ODIN:
It is me, Odin.
I cannot let you do this, Felix.
I have watched you
look like a little bitch
for 26 long years.
Look at this face.
It's pathetic.
Do not listen
to your fans, PewDiePie.
Half of them
are clearly retarded.
FELIX:
I'm fucking PewDiePie,
I do what I want.
I got the most subscribers.
I'm gonna shave.
ODIN:
Fine.
If you shave,
I'll make it so that Marzia...
won't.
(♪♪♪)